shame that sam here doesn't say i can do
this all day but i guess that's
life i think sam would say something
like i don't want to do this all day
but i will if i have to yeah it's an
important distinction to draw between
steve and sam he's pretty good at the
lab yeah you know
don't start nothing it's not going to be
nothing but if you have to i'll be here
for
the psychology background he need me i
was he would he would
be really honest yeah and he would try
and connect
in a way that lets us get us without
having to come to fisticuffs
i really don't want to be here all day
but because of my loyalty and duty
i will be here all day if needed
we can get a peaceful resolution even
better
[Music]
what is happening there reject nation we
are gonna watch today from our friends
over at new rock stars
black captain falcon and the whitey
white white
winter soldier the final episode the
breakdown in easter eggs
eric did say that sharon carter's not
the power broker oh
dude eric you lost that's what we ha
eric
lost you lost the internet eric you're
bad at your job
what i'm doing eric loss eric loss
you got so caught up in your own joke
you weren't listening that's a big part
of
improv yes which i haven't done in many
years
i will support that joke 100 and this is
what we do we come in here
we thank eric voss and the team of new
rock stars for all their hard work and
dedication and then make fun of them
yeah right away enforce the thing people
come to that party predictions
before reacting to all their hard work
maybe that's why we haven't been invited
on rogue theory in a while welcome back
to new rockstars i'm eric voss and this
is the breakdown of the falcon the
winter soldier episode 6
the finale one world one people in which
captain america sam wilson dresses up
and home team white
u.s agent john walker is bat and black
and sharon carter did to my theories
what she did to that black smasher's
face look folks my favorite part
is now always been to just go back
through the episodes and point out all
the interesting details that you might
have missed and this finale is
filled with little stuff that you can
gnaw on like sarah's tiny potato slices
or see those gross turkish delights yes
okay we open on the black smashers
disruption of the grc vote actually
carly's voice over here is actually the
same line that she spoke in latvia last
episode
they're not going to stop not
it's time bunch of lazy ass
screenwriters
plagiarizing yourselves
then a little moment with bucky that i
love
yeah telling us that some people in this
world really do learn from the history
and cap smithsonian exhibit
making it an even bigger deal when
isaiah's history will later become
restored sharon carter uses the same
mesh or they just googled it or got
information about maybe internet
school people don't only learn it from
the smithsonian museum i mean that's why
i don't know so many things
because i've never been there but that
is like a touching moment to go from
they don't call him winter soldier they
call him sergeant barnes yeah they got
it
full of identity yeah that's a that's a
powerful moment especially because like
you go to madrid
it's a winter soldier and oh here
[ __ ] bars jared carter uses the same
mesh face mask that natasha used in
winter soldier
that's where it's from now while you
could see sharon's suspicious behavior
in the post-credits scene as a set-up
for secret invasion this mask to me
signals that she herself is probably not
gonna be a squirrel
because then she wouldn't really need
that oh my god ever since you squirrels
were introduced
so whatever notice how the flag smashers
use these smoke grenades that glow green
and then sharon talks about her deadly
mercury vapor she says among other
things that she uses on that flag
smasher that emits a green smoke and
then those locks that they use on a
truck doors have eight
claws and they're strong they take
several strikes of bucky's vibranium arm
to break
remember batroc supplied this gear
courtesy of
sharon after she hired him and sharon
called someone
on the phone in the post-credits scene
super soldiers might be off the menu but
we're about to have full access to
government secrets prototype weapons
you name it i'm thinking one of sharon's
training partners and the source of this
tech could be
oscorp normally i'm hesitant to lean on
spider-man villains like green goblin
norman osborne in my mcu theories
since all those are sony properties dude
that works spider-man titles but sony
did just sign a deal with disney plus
that makes that kind of feature id
sharing a bit more likely
and by something for everyone sharon
might mean a
team of weapons tech manufacturers known
for
green glowing grenades by green goblin
and
eight armed reinforced metal gear that
you can see that's someone like doc
putting together and this comes within a
week of alfred molina talking about his
role as doc
in spiderman no way home so sam wilson
swooped oh my god
uh okay look this has been a journey the
past couple years with theory videos and
stuff
definitely awesome are very likely to
definitely
it's such a likely thing but i would
love that tie-in and
considering the fact that spider-man is
indeed one of our upcoming movies and
i don't know too much about that big
business deal that was breaking the
internet just a few days ago we were
busy working on other things
we were too important we didn't want to
read a collider.com article for a minute
yeah that would tie in with oscar but i
like the idea of seeing
exploring oscorp within a show the
industry of it because it hasn't been
introduced in the mcu yet but it's such
a big part of the
other spider-man movies prior to the mcu
it would be cool to really explore it
and maybe do get a norman osborn here oh
yeah one it would work with the show's
penchant for taking on real world issues
like weapons
giant manufacturers is definitely a part
of
yeah yeah yeah spiderman spiderman i'm
sorry peter parker
probably made those himself sam wilson
swoops in with his new suit
yeah now the music here evokes the steve
rogers captain but it is a variant that
is unique to sam
this suit's largely white design
reflects sam's look in the comics when
he becomes cap including the half
cowl that shield magnetically latches to
his back like it did with steve
and sam being in white here creates an
interesting contrast with us
agent john walker it's the same
but black sam as a black man in a role
historically seen as a white man
walker as a white man now donning the
archetypal black hat
but sam does not leave us guessing
interesting
i surprised that you didn't notice that
guy called victoria
that steve rogers was on the moon this
series never gave us an answer as to
what happened with old cap from in-game
kind of
mystery is more of a joke because i
guess these doesn't matter can only do
so much
mcu world building but for now i'm just
gonna go with cap is in space with nick
fury so
i don't i don't really feel like i need
to know
yeah i'm okay with like i don't need to
know where he is
i'm okay with them not bringing him in
or mentioning or adding to
yeah it's part of the charm is that he
went off and lived his life and
we don't know maybe he just did his
thing yeah i think it works better that
way yeah
until they bring chris evans back until
him on the move
on the moon so as the grc diplomats are
evacuated listen to this voice flaring
over the pa system
[Music]
maybe don't announce this while
terrorists have infiltrated the freaking
building
like imagine if that happened at the
capitol uh actually maybe
don't mentally compare what the black
semesters are doing to january 6th
just don't apply smash bucky a phone
keep your politics out of our political
show
do you understand me boss wow how could
you
how could how dare you i'm trying to
forget
about about everything i mean are there
people who watch falcon and winter
soldier actually who have watched this
and are truly triggered
as if they've had some horrific
traumatic incident occur to them you
know this is so riley
like stop this show is so insensitive
stop talking stop birdie just
go to twitter and yeah just like spout
off the first couple thoughts in your
mind and then let it go and
move about your day hands bucky a phone
with carly calling via that flag
smashers app
the app that bucky will later use to
trap the flag smashers they must have
thought 106 year old man couldn't work
the app they thought wrong
carly asks bucky i'm fighting for
something
have you ever been able to say the same
you don't think i ever fought for
something bigger than myself that's all
i ever tried to do
and i failed twice yeah bucky fought
freaking thanos you dummy
he has two losses they reversed his
losses in infinity war
and in world war ii you could argue
though i don't really know if it's fair
to say he
lost that really everything he did he
could have killed hitler man that's
right
he had the opportunity that truck by
kick flipping the shield and then
tossing it out the window first to break
it
before swooping back out to catch it
this is also kind of how he had to enter
the building by
smashing the window with the shield
first see if those were condensed i just
given him a vibranium head covering here
weirdly exposed you wouldn't have to
worry about smashing through the box
himself he's made a vibranium at that
point
sam uses we look i i know a lot of
people don't stick around for our
breakdown part
or a review part after the reaction
that's uh
something that's absolutely true is look
he needs a helmet
he needs to help seem wise i appreciate
for like your first episode especially
since there's so much emphasis on the
fact that it's a black man taking on the
captain america outfit let him be seen
let it
really be known like this is a black man
donning the captain america outfit he's
the new captain america
i think though he needs a helmet i still
think he needs it would be a safe thing
to assume
like when those pipe things fall on him
or whatever at one point in the
episode's big
giant dead hit his head he would have
died you know yeah
it's a helmet ladder his head all across
the inside of that half couch
you know easy you just get a brain
aneurysm you can just like a concussion
sam uses red wing to scan the grc
hostages and on the screen you can see
her name
ayla perez she's a background in the
philippine air force with experience
flying both competitors
and chinook helicopters
i tell sam that perez has experience
with multiple types of helicopters and
that he can trust her to climb into that
seat and pull it out of a dive even
though that would probably be very
difficult for anyone other than tom
cruise to do sam saves the nypd pilots
shielding one with his wings
and the cap shield on that's such a
beautiful shot there's so many beautiful
yeah notice how this shield has a
lighter more tinny sound than the
deeper mystical hum of the vibranium
there's a lot of different you know
oh you did me to dedicate the
differences here he falls in the
construction pit
he screams
echoing his scream as he fell from the
train in the first cap film
the scream that inspired his winter
soldier whale which we have not heard on
this show
since his wakandan campfire going clear
moment and since he's no longer hunted
bucky now
sticks the superhero landing oh hey by
the way our anarchy assembled shirt is
still
available along with our amazing new
zemo design though we are running low
on supply for both of those so you gotta
move fast you can support us this way
[ __ ] they're overstocked
yeah that's just a selling technique
just putting walker at this crossroad
[Music]
but get one and notice composer henry
jackman brings back his theme from civil
war here to underline walker's come to
jesus moment choosing to save the
hostages instead of seeking revenge on
carly
should say after what he did in episodes
four and five for john walker it's not
really come to jesus as it is jesus
actually pulling away his mesh face mask
to reveal it's manifesto underneath ah
it's going to help but walker's choice
is emphasized by what he does let drop
his
jesus this is mephisto that's what i
took
and it's the true shield that lifts it
bring me in the shield like a rising sun
saving these lives an inverse of the way
john walker framed it eclipsing nico
and ending his life sam uses his drone
boost
similar to iron man's drones in
spider-man homecoming
really with this suit sam is truly a
fusion of captain america and iron man
with the vibranium tech of black panther
well i also gotta say too
something with the cinematography that
really stands out in all these final
moments
and i'm not sure what the intentional
choice of it is the color blue can
represent
bravery loyalty uh it's also
the color of captain ameri like steve
rogers suit and this is
sam into his acceptance of becoming
captain america during this whole fight
scene especially when he does save like
you got kind of that darker more sad
gloomy blue until sam shows up with the
shield
this big illuminating savior-like blue
yeah i'm not sure what the choice would
be but i have like my mind's
obviously going into 80 thoughts on many
reasons why it could just be the
reflection of the city
lights looking like new york city at
night
it's 80 thoughts baby that's all it is
they're definitely expressing a lot via
the lighting and i think it probably
kind of encapsulates all those themes to
some degree and it also enhances the
contrast because sam's suit has so much
white on it too like i think it brings
out the lighter tones in that blue
lighting anyway it's gotta be an
emotional reason john dubba d
and if you screenshot this at the right
moment it looks like bucky's dancing
next to john walker
where's the super cut one hour one
hour's worth i want it an onlooker
watches this calling him black falcon
like the kid in baltimore in episode two
[ __ ] he catches a rebarb spear i love
how this dude catches pretty much
everything hurled at him on the show
walker with the shield on the truck the
knife in episode 4 the shield again in
the fight last episode get this man a
goalie mask
and then sharon is revealed to be the
power broker a twist that seems both
overly
obvious but also pretty inconsistent
with the character's past behavior and
timeline
we go all into it and inside marvel but
hey the good news is according to this
you seem like you really don't like it
mastermind who also makes things weirdly
a little bit i mean not today entirely
disagree but yeah
now you could argue sharon never
explicitly declares herself the power
broke
that is true super soldiers how much
power does the power broker
she just didn't deny you so you're the
power broker
but sharon kills batroc only because he
threatens to
expose her as the power broker to the
world as a woman behind the curtain she
needs anonymity and if she wasn't the
power broker here she wouldn't care what
patrock told people
so sam shows up to fight so she has the
power broken
good spiderman context while fighting
thanos but sam avoids fighting
really quick that is true it is like it
was so obvious i didn't think it was the
case because it just seemed too obvious
yeah it just seemed like oh man
well that would be a twist that's the
first twist i would think of
yeah it's like such a setup that i'm
like it's gotta be like a misleading
yeah exactly
i feel like general television but
especially coming after one division
where there was
so much of setup and rest directs and
stuff like it's gotta just be
could just be a misdirect it's good it
is true there is some it's consistent it
is
we don't know what her life's been like
in the past five years that really made
her change we're gonna need some scenes
to establish that if we really care
enough
she feels like a different character
sort of every movie
it's only been three things yeah she's
kind of the same in civil war and
i guess winter soldier yeah soldier
she's undercover
romantically interested looking like it
all right fine isn't it
that's right up on the romantic thing
yeah so and then five years later
she's a criminal
it tracks you know metrics yeah it goes
dude steve's absence affects a lot of
people it does matter
by propelling her into the life of
utmost crime he does these flips and
somersaults the same ones that we saw
him training with last episode so
that's stuntman look at that stunt man
training
carly says
if i wanted you dead yes i'm allergic to
iron man saying this to the previous
camp in civil war
stay down final warning yeah shame that
sam here doesn't say i can do this all
day but
i guess that's steve's line walker
quotes abraham lincoln
mercy bear is rich i think sam would say
something like
i don't want to do this all day but i
will if i have to yeah
it's an important distinction to draw
between steve and sam
he's pretty good at the lab yeah you
know don't start nothing it's not going
to be
nothing but if you have to i'll be here
for the psychology background he needs
he
would he would be really honest yeah
and he would try and connect in a way
that lets us get out of this without
having to come to fisticuffs
i really don't want to be here all day
but because of my loyalty and duty i
will be here all day
if needed we can get a peaceful
resolution even better
i'll give a [ __ ] what you guys think
that that was hilarious yeah we were
good that was really
fun that was the thing i've ever said
all year mercy
bear is richer fruit than strict justice
yeah the
president who oversaw the u.s civil war
another sign that walker is learning the
lessons that these avengers had to learn
the hard way in their civil war
so carly dies in sam's arms holding the
hamsa pendant that she held at
mamadanya's death bed and as sam carries
her body
his outstretched wings evoke that of an
angel delivering the soul to the
afterlife or really john i'm a fist
don't she's going to kill how the
reporters don't know what to make
out captain falcon
[Music]
[Applause]
telling them that they gotta do better
and if i can do better and you can do
better maybe we all can do better yeah
pretty great really even deeper than
sam's great points are the fact that we
are seeing a black captain america
publicly speaking truth to power it is a
core component to cap's character that
we saw when steve debated nick fury and
captain america winter soldier or stood
up to 20 stock in civil war and bucky
acknowledges this evolution
nice job cap thanks
bucky pat's the shield he's both oh
nice job steve for choosing this guy and
the last time we see sam in this suit on
this series he soars across the frame
with the shield briefly in close-up
gliding past us meanwhile the rest of
the flag smashers go boom are you
looking for this
hated by osnick
[Music]
that was good comedy that was well done
editors whoever thought to do that
well done brilliant brilliant
i don't have a third thing i feel like
you should buy a hundred pairs of
bessies for that
zemo's butler from episode three and
this news gets to zemo on the raft
prison from civil war he's wearing the
same jumpsuits that they all wore then
on his shelf are a few books russian
poet alexander pushkin
and views of nature by alexander von
humboldt
i guess this is the alexander shelf
meanwhile the book zemo reads
looks like the one he had to sell on
episode three fortune is a river which
explores the friendship between
machiavelli and leonardo da vinci in
renaissance era florence italy
now i previously speculated that this
book meant that the machiavellian zemo
had a secret partnership with some da
vinci figure in the shadows
someone like looks like our friend zemo
kind of got the last laugh yes zemo's da
vinci was defontaine
since oznik likely could not have
arranged that bombing himself it is
clear valve hey don't underestimate him
he's a nimble guy well maybe i did
no i'm kidding i didn't or did i so the
fact that val has been in touch with
zemo
who's on the raft a facility overseen by
thunderbolt ross
tells us that our theory that val could
be assembling a team of anti-heroes like
the thunderbolts or dark avengers may
still be happening
and by saying that black smashers deaths
is more likely yes tells us
division as opposed to working for hydra
or something but val has suited up john
walker as
us agent the dark suited assassin from
the comments
us agent also leads the dark avengers
later in the comics
and val ends by saying things are about
to get
weird so when they do
we're not gonna need a captain america
we're gonna need
a u.s agent weird
well one way to look at weird is that
val knows about the scroll infiltration
and that the secret invasion is coming
and in a world where no one trusts
anyone having an untrustworthy dark cap
is more valuable but val also said
last episode that the government's
ownership of the shield is a legal gray
area making me wonder if she knows about
old cap
and how he brought that shield from an
alternate timeline making it technically
the property of an
alternate timeline government so maybe
the weirdness she's referring to is the
coming multiverse crisis
something that we could see more of with
loki in the tv meanwhile bucky makes
true amends with
how weird yeah weird
weird weird i got a question beard's
weird what's your question when she says
we don't need a captain america we need
a u.s
agent i didn't quite get that what does
that mean i think what's the difference
between a us agent and a captain america
one operates on a more clandestine
basis it was just a cool line right
what's cool
i heard he's being character superhero
title captain and agent are both you
know
positions that you can hold varying
ranks and and whatnot
but at the same time i'm like there's
not really a pun
you know inverted referee it's not like
one piggy backs onto the other it's just
like oh yeah that's kind of
it's similar but different there's a bit
of a weight that
didn't quite hit for me there only
because i was like but
what is that what do you either do
that's what's the harder impact here of
like when the world's in trouble we
don't need to captain america
yeah why why a us agent and not a
captain america
yeah cause u.s agents still doesn't help
me understand any better what things
getting weird means or why
that would help as opposed to having a
captain america as a us
agent means loyalty to u.s whereas
captain america he does not want to live
by accordance to the government he does
not necess you know what i mean he's all
about morality and if he disagrees with
government
he will he will not follow suit whereas
u.s agent
would is that maybe what it is sure i
mean that's the best i've heard so far
guys you're overthinking this stop bucky
makes true amends with mr nakajima and
officially crosses mr nakajima's name
off the list a list whose names that we
have broken down in previous breakdowns
and he leaves that notebook as a gift
for dr raynor leaving the frame with an
empty couch and empty woods bucky is now
out of the woods
i don't need therapy anymore nope i am
all
of you i have fixed these last hundred
years of trauma
gone because i crossed off my book i
flashed back once to my time in wakanda
and that's really all i needed man i
was going to talk about now i'm all
unpacked doc
no more baggage sam visits isaiah
bradley again
black captain america huh damn right
and right as sam says this behind him
eli bradley enters the frame
eli is the future young avenger patriot
another black cat figure but for now
he's still waiting his turn in line
behind sam
meanwhile behind isaiah during the scene
is interesting graffiti the words
why me reflecting how both of these men
had the burden of captain america's
legacy thrust upon them now isaiah
brings up martin malcolm and mandela
of course referring to civil rights
leaders martin luther king jr malcolm x
and nelson mandela but my favorite thing
about this
is this atlanta neighborhood where they
shot this scene is home to where martin
luther king was born the famous
[Music]
in episodes two and five so sam brings
isaiah to his new addition to cap's
smithsonian exhibit including this
plaque that details the history that
isaiah told him about along with this
old photograph this shows black world
war ii soldiers that actually inspired a
panel in truth red white and black
i love how this bookends the shot that
we saw back in episode one
sam's reflection as he stared at that
shield in the display case it was
actually him
realizing people who look like him have
been erased from this history
as sam's translucent form in that scene
suggested
but now sam has transformed this from an
optical illusion
to a tangible reality with this statue
of isaiah
and we celebrate with a family cookout a
reminder that fixing the wilson family
vote has always been a personal metaphor
for sam for restoring the legacy of the
shield which he has done as curtis
harding's on and on plays
the final credit revises the series
title to
captain america then we get to this
poster
that would be so cool they have to wait
till monday
the carter name has always been
synonymous with service
trust welcome home agent carter two
references there to
peggy carter sharon's great aunt who
will show up in what if
and hopefully a future film with steve
rogers in that alternate timeline
it was actually announced that a fourth
captain america film is in development
from the falcon of the winter soldier
showrunner mountain spellman but that's
probably going to follow sam wilson not
the chris evans steve rogers cap films
emir how messed up would it be right
back to steve
not for a movie though you can't have
sam do a move or some other criminal
group from the marvel
hydra 10 rings hammer aim oscorp whoever
this is it's most likely said enough
sharon to return in the series armor
wars
which rhodey is going to star in this
mini series about the weaponry of the
mcu getting in the wrong hands
but my favorite detail why wasn't rody
helping out there
yeah he was in the beginning why was he
just beast out this whole time he could
have easily swooped in
new york like so many of them yeah like
daredevil jessica
[Laughter]
they're all there okay well you know as
she exits the courtroom the camera
suddenly slows down
and she looks directly at camera it is
as if she knows how much her power
broker reveal broke
us but i gotta hand it to you agent
carter
but it was you oh
thank everyone so much for supporting us
throughout this breakdown series
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
and subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of this
other marvel stuff loki really anything
that will break my heart by ralph
bonering my theories
boner bye
dude he definitely didn't look as uh
emotionally exhausted
no as by the time we got to the wanda
vision finale
yeah yeah you're looking better eric
yeah
everyone be nice to eric voss all right
are people being mean to him
well i don't know i mean i saw a tweet
the other day which was like you know i
love making these theories and
breakdowns but i'm gonna have to
like you know mute some of the
particularly harsh
[ __ ] that's coming my way wow be nice
eric boz
yeah the entire new rockstar is crew
he's doing his best
zach and philip and everybody over there
they're they're they're
putting together they're crunching these
things down
and editing and researching more people
are getting more excited to say
you're wrong than to come to you and say
you were right it's weird how the world
works because he's
people are right about a lot but then
once as we see it in comments
all the time we could talk for 45
minutes
get one thing wrong it's like oh that's
the main comment now
that becomes your actually it's
pronounced
oh boy yep can't can't go wrong there
all right guys well this was fun man
falcon a winner soldier
captain america and the winner's soldier
i would love it if it said
captain america and the white winter
soldier
that's emphasized only the only the
white king
yes white iron man subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button and subscribe to any rock
stars if you haven't done so
already oh [ __ ] we gotta find something
to cover in may till june comes around
no
so whatever we cover may we just be like
all right end of this
superman and lois will definitely fill
that oh superman lois will
fill the void absolutely the fan base is
just
as strong as it is i mean that's a great
show though it's a good show
damn good [ __ ] yeah you guys should
watch it don't sleep dirty watch it
do it all right we'll see you guys